[Music]
how many 20 17 guys welcome to one of my
first love
thanks BDO Scopus around one simple
question what do you wear to the White
House right now we're about to head into
the White House Jenna got her back
stolen this ones are so good so I mean
it's the airport social-media influencer
you never use vine well it's too late
because it's no longer with us anymore
[__] you've never eaten before we
have it I'm still hungry I think very
nice Steelers lost I don't think I'm
another suitable down
here's some hi it's so good you wearing
your easy come easy sous-sous the boost
no needy communities
idiot
I am the careless I'm reckless accidents
happen
oh just drops this one is for Tom Brady
and we're gonna call this but the flight
tape mess mess mess mess alright that's
it I gotta clean up my kill zone here oh
wait oh oh that's not glue hey you know
what's a great idea when you're cooking
why don't you wear a freaking sweater
that has the biggest most obnoxious
sleeves I have a wonderful idea
[Music]
I only made a little tiny mess if you
make this for your lover your lover's
gonna be like wow I love you I'm
freaking out like I'm freaking out it's
just a tiny mini pizza girl I can't even
turn around because I'm in such a tight
space you look good
they both fell out I can't even pick it
up with one hand unfortunately for many
of you have been waiting patiently for
this video when will I just steam lose
her air pods and guess what 64 days
hello can you believe this we happen it
is being Hawaii at the same time like
crazy we did not plan this
oh my you're beautiful hmm
we need a microwave I got one you're
here on the table I've opened a lot of
Apple products before this is not the
handiwork of an original unbox iPhone
pretty sure yesterday I probably put in
15 hours because I didn't really leave
the couch guys I'm starting to get
worried about her she won't go home
because she was one of felt like okay it
tastes like play-doh or in Cueto no I
haven't played oh wow I'm going to be
importing all of these amiibo into Zelda
breath of the wild this has become an
actual serious issue and I'm concerned
about my well-being because there is
nothing else that I want to do except
play Zelda breath with a freaking wild
this is the happiest day ever
technology is incredible super breasts
look at our balls look at this little
thing this is home really nice field
what do I got around New York City I
believe in you just joining us are not
just any people they are the Power
Rangers so here's what it actually looks
like right up here everyone to the Power
Rangers virtual reality experience how
do they get them to your door I don't
know even how like this is possible
we're trying grinding today that's what
we're doing at eatin cake and pizza
these are my friends hold on best
friends I always say I'm not gonna do it
this time I'm not I don't need it and
then here we are at it again
[Music]
we got my phone guys do you think I
should keep this phone or should I stick
with my jet black ball I'm returning my
red eye but I just realized that I don't
like the color
the transaction is complete and then
you've got her glazed meat which I am
the button believably surprised at how
good that actually make it yeah let's
try there's Jenna ready to hike oh no I
made it backwards so we Long Beach for
the Toyota Grand Prix no sound Connor
okay this is salted chocolate why don't
we just cut off um like the pieces of
whoo this is interesting
oh it's also um topped with fun look at
this stuff that they gave us to work
with how are you supposed to do anything
this is the best
[Music]
let's take a taste oh my good it's like
it has a sour taste that's perfect
this is the life but wila do you believe
it's Friday night Jen I'm me my
cellphone nibby Libby I'm just you know
swimming out here just see what I can
see I just bought these shoes today -
yes I am
is that bad - yes that's an apple -
that's all looks really good
what the hook not a secret that I'm
obsessed with my Nintendo switch still
yes I'm still obsessed do you how to do
that very fussy I'm getting the pairing
option again
do you need my Wi-Fi no I mean this is
this is the future here so all of our
scholarship players they can come in
before and after hours they have a
scholarship program for League of
Legends that's what you're telling me -
so awesome Wow look at this thing it's
huge
that's not the right color there's also
an undo here's the nice red
[Laughter]
get a box of lies this is what you got
again but I'm most excited about what
jobs are you going to create that do not
exist now yes yeah so good luck here I
take a quick selfie impeccable timing
yeah this is still a little doughy
[Music]
when Chicago you go to Coachella
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I just want to say you should be very
careful with knives because they are not
a toy you should not play with them it's
still making noises this is crazy
snack sacks grab them share them zip
them take them you can't that's
something you can't
[Music]
[Applause]
was incredible Justine thank you so much
you have very cos I got a job and a
future I got my friend back I'm uh I'm
spike an see you filming me but like I
think it's like an hour body experience
I'm freaking out
[Music]
so ever since the Mac operating system
was called Yosemite and then the next
version was El Capitan that's the only
thing that I wanted to do I wanted to go
and visit you cemani and then visit el
coffee times so we're here we made it
my goal has been complete is that our El
Capitan it's ok well yeah I'll see you
later Justine this could be it ok 1 2 3
4 my fingers crossed at a MacPro
announcement
I feel like this WWDC will not
disappoint original Mac Pro came out in
2013 we've been waiting for a Mac Pro
I'm gonna spray-paint this thing
fluorescent
round number one yeah just like boxing I
already got a hundred point
oh I keep wanting to call it xbox
Scorpio so now it's not I think they
look like on the switch
I'm loving the one color on each side
joy Khan's man hot pink though gonna
look so great
I am don't pick up my controller and I'm
gonna throw it over to i-15 and Golden
Boy and Paul hey guys welcome to the
world premiere of Star Wars Battlefront
two's multiplayer gameplay assault on
alright so I was at the e3 press
conference and when we saw you on that
screaming three trailer people are going
absolutely nuts tomorrow you'll be
throwing cars
to be
video game I never thought I needed
reading glasses but I don't even think
reading glasses would help out with this
we need a freaking magnifying glass so
I'm in Toronto right now this is
actually my first time here I have never
really been to Canada due to this
experience isn't a one-way broadcast
it's a two-way conversation and one of
the features that makes you special is
the way that Park fans are able to come
together to shape communities around
them your favorite content
[Music]
I'm gonna throw up I don't think I like
this
[Applause]
a bad turn it is but I don't know what
else to call us I mean they used to call
us youtubers or creator they're really
good they're super good
like I feel like these trees are just
becoming out in hitting me
[Music]
thank you okay so I'm gonna say that the
echo show is pretty cool even though
this is something that isn't really that
revolution to finish that yet this is
Madison Square Park neither one of us is
we live here you're visiting I'm
visiting from Boston this is cool
[Music]
oh my god is it good Matt hey you gotta
sit down you gotta try this that looks
so good Jen I know what we need hmm a
drill we know how many calories this is
treat lady I can't believe it
this box was all beat up and I was like
ah there's probably nothing cool in here
[Music]
the 3dsxl is a little bit taller he
should have been a baller shot caller
[Music]
I have little upstairs that's why I keep
my house ready to knock up stairs
what's happening up there so I don't
know if like this one would work this is
my personal Shetty her excited how do
you have that have to know why you've
heard this this is my bowie knife but
when I said serrated that's I didn't
mean
oh so aggressive the iPhone 8 is real
but the fact that we're already talking
about the iPhone 90s come on I've never
seen any iPhone 8 rumors I've never seen
anything I just I don't I just stay away
today I just installed iOS 11 wait a
minute hey Siri what time is it the time
is 11 p.m.
that's my look like it's your hair and
eyebrows have come a very long this was
Halloween oh this is a year after the
iPhone Vil video and I'm kind of just
revisiting the place that I went I was
just looking in my meal and I'm
seriously incredibly impressed
[Music]
[Applause]
I got it Wow still alive not yet that
you told that's huge
thank you can you tell them I did a good
job you did great
why are you DJing
yeah this upgrade this is a Martha
Stewart action here Rachael Ray would be
like girl you're so good at everything
making frozen food oh goodness
there's so many goodies in here I was
trying to be ketchup it may be given to
most people with not having seen the
movie are we can hope that five words
what's what where we now are hogs me wow
you can kind of see it through the
glasses it's copper it's not rose gold I
don't like this color at all I'm just
gonna be a hundred percent completely
honest with you
[Music]
it's not good at all
do you know what that sound is
that sound means Oh baby we're charging
and I'm happy about it to be doing a
very good job on this one
hey Jenna what's your favorite color
blue oh yeah
slo-mo sizzle well is this color I might
die today I look so dumb in that like I
your Oh liars you pull it all the way
down
[Music]
wait I'm scared he's like so excited so
she sent me a few of these things
already those of you that I do on oh I
have a small mishap
I'd like to know is how many kids are
gonna use this as their back-to-school
back your like every one of those advent
calendars like the path Alba Christmas
but this is like the countdown to my
Christmas and that's iPhone announcement
they have an announcement to make and
I'm not sure how to make this
announcement without freaking out
[Music]
usually when packing the best advice is
to pack the largest things first I
didn't in here do my own advice first
person that I ran into what I stepped up
to the theater was Steve Wozniak and you
know it's one of those things like when
you meet your heroes we don't know what
to say I didn't know what to say but I
said thank you thank you for everything
and then he walked away here it is the
iPhone 10 it was officially announced
today and I've got it
the white version and there's also a
space free version and this thing is
absolutely
[Music]
I was trying to stop it look at this I
am crying in my own paper with my face
I'll make my eyes big I kind of look
like in the Moriya brothers movie the
goombas I just take like a normal
picture oh my god all the effects are
still on don't want large eyes I want
mine they seem to be the same size so
okay good to know
this is someone who is genuinely
enthusiastic about iPhones and
everything is bigger if I'm kind of just
eyeballing this I mean you can sort of
very vaguely tell that it's slightly
more raised oh this matches my knife so
right here is the little eject button
when you press this it prepares your
device before come here for tablet mode
what apps cannot live without No
clickbait hello only clickbait if it's
not true starting off here from the top
I've got my calendar which one looks the
most like us where's the boating thing
I'm uniting down that does not look like
pumpkin to shut up what do you think it
it is encrusted on top you guys I have
ever had we're like just did you make
apple pie but I completely messed this
up from the beginning I was wondering
what the plan was I've never seen it
done that I've never even maybe you're
onto something
hence the name Platinum hello baby
[Music]
the only thing that would make me
happier as if I could eat this cookie
while playing cookie GM while my cookie
is in the game I feel like that's some
crazy inception nonsense
doc right on and back to the future
this is so bright so I'm definitely
gonna mess around with this because I
feel like this isn't the ideal setup I
don't like where this microphone
placement is you think I could make it
no no no this you didn't even hit the
backboard it is Super Mario cereal it's
just like Lucky Charms yes sir it was a
one-person job I don't know how much I
was like yes I'm very excited we are
alive like very soon as
I'm kind of scared
things just got so crazy from the simple
maybe it was a long way down I just feel
a thing behind the city reason
[Music]
happy vlog this we are making a s'more I
think a bit of a small happening here I
mean this is the this is a perfect tree
topper I think everyone should do this
for their Christmas trees fill a very
large range of emotions right now these
are my youtuber gingerbread cookies and
what's great is as a youtuber I feel
like we've got a great community and
here we are all unified hi around the
tree okay let's go buy a bunch of cards
just now watch me I'm watching
[Music]
a lot of them I know that's that's like
an acquired taste oh wow yeah you know
the head of that look hard I'm putting
myself in the freezer but you should see
you in a couple of years I'll come back
I'll come feel like Jenna's and
cryofreeze I had all intentions of
making it as beautiful no just looks
like trash is this something is this
like I put on your head she couldn't I
have absolutely no idea what this is but
suck Liam activity yeah let's go fire it
up we can plug in now we can fire it up
that was the whole thing you just got
served
[Music]